it may be the most famous
anti-war painting ever made but after
more than 35 years
a tapestry copy of pablo picasso's
guernica
is gone from the united nations picasso
made the original in 1937
at the height of the spanish civil war
following a vicious bombing campaign in
basque country
the painting is searing in detail a
mother holding a dead child
women running from the scene animals
suffering
a tapestry was commissioned by former
vice president nelson rockefeller
and put on loan to the un in 1984.
the rockefellers had already donated
land for the u.n to save succeeding
generations from the scourge of war
but recently nelson rockefeller jr
notified the un of the family's
intention to retrieve it
a spokesperson told cbs news the u.n is
grateful the tapestry was on loan for so
long
but un secretary general antonio
gutierrez was more blunt
also telling cbs news this week quote it
is horrible
horrible that it's gone if you've been
to the u.n it's a was an unforgettable
part
of of that scene for 35 years now press
conferences
were held in front of it so they now
have a commission that's looking into
whatever is going to replace
yournika it will be interesting to see
what they decide upon
there's so many options out there